[Music]
what we're bringing to the screen for
the first time is the live-action Star
Wars
[Music]
thanks plays about five years after
Return of the Jedi the series follows a
Mandalorian this new character is a
gunfighter a bounty hunter a citizen of
the underworld on the outer reaches of
the galaxy
it starts off with him just hunting down
quarries making his money this is a
territory you've never met before in a
period of time that you've never seen
there's just an aesthetic to the
mandalorian that is extremely powerful
mysterious this armor that harkens to
medieval knights
it's relatable we're all kind of covered
in our own armor here we are they agree
in terms of directors I think John chose
the team really really well
obviously gave Brice Deborah Ric and
then taiga different voices and
personalities that each of the
filmmakers were bringing to the table
and wanted to bring that to the world
with Star Wars
everybody's pulling us we have involved
in the story
this series offers the opportunity to
introduce new planets
the races and species
these starships
however we wanted to feel completely
connected and familiar
it's truly an adventure Star Wars
adventure
as the heart that Star Wars has always
been about
[Applause]
people feel gritty it will feel real
but anybody could sit down their seat
and watch and enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
hi everyone is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new Star Wars Mandalorian news
they actually just confirmed they're
gonna be working on season two's we do
break down of a trailer footage and talk
about what's going on with this stuff in
the next couple of weeks because d23 is
coming up right after Comic Con and
they're showing off way more footage
while I was making this video they also
released a new clip of Jon Favreau
talking about the series explaining a
bunch of stuff so here is that clip can
you tell us anything about the
Mandalorian or surgery what do you want
to know what secret but I'll tell you
what's going on in it what happens it's
you know it's about a bounty hunter it's
after Return of the Jedi so the Empire
is gone and all hell's breaking loose in
the Outer Rim and and it's about the you
know scum and villainy that that now
once you take out the rule of law what
happens chaos takes over and you have a
lot of the unseemly character it's based
on current events
it's kind of like you know when you meet
han Solo at the beginning of Star Wars
or I do hope and you have sort of the
star star port bar and I always love
those characters I always love the
rogues gallery of bounty hunters and in
Empire Strikes Back and I always want to
see more about it I got together with a
guy Dave Filoni who's my partner on this
one is producer and we're writing the
stuff and and coming up it's honestly
like turning over your your toy chest
and playing with all the Star Wars toys
together we're having a great time it's
all new characters it's gonna be on
Disney Plus coming up in the fall and
we're done with the first season i'm i
was actually writing part of the second
season now so i'm having a blast
well look at this you're having a good
life having everything you do is turns
into gold it's amazing we're in the
middle of convention season so of course
they're gonna be hyping up everyone's
big projects but we'll do a new round of
that imax ticket giveaway or you
attitudes enter is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite star wars series on
the video and a lot of people are
expecting this to evoke a lot of Clone
Wars mythology because Dave Filoni is
working on it he shows up during that
teaser trailer talking about it he and
Jon Favreau collaborated when he was
making the Mandalorian series because
Jon Favreau is technically the
showrunner he wrote most of the scripts
but Dave Filoni is sort of the Jedi
Master of Star Wars TV series at
Lucasfilm so they paired them together
and they had formerly worked together on
the actual Clone Wars series because Jon
Favreau himself played the previz 'la
character during that the story that jon
favreau told about how he met Dave
Filoni while he was working on Iron Man
1 was pretty cool so he went to
Skywalker Sound at the Lucasfilm ranch
to mix the sound for Iron Man 1 way back
in 2007 and around that time Dave Filoni
was there working on the Clone Wars
series so they got to talking they
became friends and that's how jon
favreau wound up playing a character on
Star Wars the Clone Wars you also
probably saw recently that they dropped
a teaser trailer for Clone Wars season 6
because they're bringing that back for
more episodes as part of this big Disney
Plus streaming service programming push
we was hoping for Kenobi why are you
here
but as to say in the trailer footage
they just introduced some of the core
characters there was some separate
footage we only have potato versions of
it right now so the quality isn't so
great d23 will probably be where they
release some more high quality footage
but you all know Pedro Pascal is playing
the mandalorian it's very much in the
vein of an old-school Western Clint
Eastwood style man with no name so just
a really badass bounty hunter in the
Outer Rim trying to make a living for
himself five years after Return of the
Jedi Carl Weathers is playing a
character named grief carga he's the
leader of the bounty hunters guild that
the Mandalorian belongs to so obviously
there's a whole bunch of other bounty
hunters Taika Waititi was just revealed
to be doing the voice for ig-88 so ig-88
will be a pretty big character on the
series probably an antagonist but part
of the fun of the series is that because
it's about all these bounty hunters most
of them are pretty terrible on a normal
day but not all of them are evil
necessarily so very cool gray area that
all the stuff operates in within the
Star Wars universe Gina Carano is one of
the other main characters of the series
she's playing a bounty hunter as part of
this guild she says that she's a former
ex rebel shock trooper that just never
could acclimate to civilian life
post-war Werner Herzog's character was
featured prominently in the other big
trailer that they showed off because it
sort of sets them off on the plot like
what is he doing during this series and
why is it the other bounty hunters end
up coming after him Werner Herzog plays
one of the administrators of the town
that the Mandalorian is in here he hires
him to track down a bounty which is
basically like a little girl precious
cargo they call it to bring it back it
offers him a payday that he can't refuse
it's a bunch of best scar alloy which is
the special medal that Mandalorians used
to make their famous armor it's
incredibly rare in almost priceless so
it seems like it's too good to be true
but the whole idea is that he probably
winds up finding out why they want the
little girl and then ends up wanting to
protect her through the series and then
they set the other bounty hunters from
the guild against him Giancarlo Esposito
is playing an imperial character you see
him in his Thai fighter pilots uniform
flying a TIE fighter and then ordering
this hit on the village here they
haven't given the exact premiere date
yet but it sounds like it's gonna be
somewhere in mid-november before the
Thanksgiving holiday because they
probably want everybody to buy the
Disney streaming server
and spend all of their Thanksgiving
holiday watching all this programming
we've only seen a little bit of footage
from Star Wars Episode nine but it
actually sounds like people are even
more excited about Star Wars the
Mandalorian episodes than they are about
Star Wars Episode nine which I never
would have guessed a long time ago
there's still a lot of Star Wars Clone
Wars fans that are super excited about
that series coming back so hopefully now
they'll have some really badass
live-action series to go with some of
that animated programming but you've
probably heard that they are putting
Star Wars movies on hiatus for a couple
of years until they start whatever the
next trilogy is going to be there'll be
Star Wars movies till the end of time
but they're just taking a couple years
break between the end of Star Wars
Episode nine in the beginning of
whatever Star Wars Episode 10 is going
to be they finally can burn that they're
working on a Star Wars The Old Republic
series we have written Jon Favreau
already said that he's writing episodes
for season two of the Mandalorian I'm
guessing that that would premiere next
year sometime they sounds like they've
already kind of soft renewed it for
season two because it cost so much money
to produce they want it to be one of
their flagship shows for the Disney Plus
streaming service to get people to
subscribe to it so they got a lock a lot
of this stuff down really far in advance
we haven't gotten a lot of news about
the suppose that Obi one TV series
remember it was going to be a movie now
apparently it's going to be a
live-action series it's like the
mysterious Hawkeye TV series that Marvel
is doing that they haven't absolutely
confirmed yet but the idea is is through
this Disney Plus streaming service
you'll get all these live-action Star
Wars TV series episodes but you'll also
get all the Marvel stuff there's also a
bunch of Pixar TV series its basically
programming and movies from all of
disneys brands so whatever your poison
is it sounds like Disney will at least
have some of it and I will be doing
episodes for the mandalorian and all the
Marvel TV series but if something comes
up that you guys really want me to do
videos for on it just let me know in the
comments
really quick reminder about Comic Con
next week too Comic Con is happening
pretty much all of next week there'll be
all kinds of trailers but there's not
really gonna be any big Star Wars
footage dropping that's all going to be
d23 at the very end of
I'll remind people about that next week
and I'll name a giveaway winner when I
post new Marvel this weekend so while
you wait for everything click here for
that brand new spider-man far from home
ending scene in the spider-man 3 teaser
and click here for all my spider-man far
from home Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you